according to the book of Genesis in the
beginning there was a great emptiness on
the first day God created heaven and
earth calling a light day and the
darkness night following this and in the
coming days God created humanity giving
them dominion over the earth and
instructing them to be fruitful and to
multiply and so on the seventh day God
looked upon his creation of every animal
of the sea and the air in the land he
looked upon Adam and Eve he looked upon
every plant and tree and at last God
rested
[Music]
this creation story like so many others
before it seeks to answer the questions
that have been the source of mankind's
existential crisis why are we here who
created us and what if there is one is
the meaning of life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
at the beginning of all things there was
simply the one above all and from
nothing it crafted the first firmament
in turn and driven by loneliness the
first firmament created the first forms
of life naming its children aspirants
they look to their Creator in turn in a
yet the universe traveling throughout
this undeveloped space the aspirants
sought to create life but like all
servants to a creator sought its
approval as well for those forms of life
deemed acceptable by the first universe
their progression was allowed to
continue but for those deemed
unacceptable their progress was halted
their lives ended and the creation
process was begun anew however in a far
corner of the universe a small band of
aspirants was planning insurrection
in the eyes of these rebels the life
created by their brothers and sisters
was a half-measure beings crafted with
the belief that the first universe was
their only true God seeing this is
short-sighted
and believing that both life and the
universe should evolve and come to
understand growth change and mortality
these aspirants abandon their namesakes
and rechristened themselves the
Celestials branding them heretics and
ordering their destruction the first
universe watched on as the Celestials
and aspirants were thrown into a cosmic
holy war resulting in the deaths and
destructions of all the aspirants in
existence and the first universe itself
shattering into an infinite number of
pieces and thus the multiverse was born
in the aftermath of the celestial holy
war and recognizing its failures with
the first universe the one above all set
to organizing a new and intricately
designed order of power within the
multiverse
serving the role of safeguarding
existence itself the Living Tribunal was
designed to exist without emotion and to
operate under three tenets number one to
ensure cosmic balance is maintained
number two to ensure no universe became
more powerful than the others and number
three to ensure balance between the
forces of good and evil in order to
carry out these three tenants the Living
Tribunal was provided with three phases
representing equity vengeance and
necessity using these three phases the
tribunal would look upon any scenario
requiring its involvement and make an
equitable determination as to whether or
not a punishment was needed if all three
phases were in agreement the actions of
the tribunal could range from the
removal of one's powers to the complete
and utter destruction of entire
universes and so following this the one
above all turned to the Infinity stones
creating a cycle of infinite duplication
the infinite power of the stones would
serve as the source of creation for
their respective universes the space
stone would create the physical space of
the universe including any and all
pocket dimensions the reality stone
would fill that space with all atomic
and subatomic matter the soul stone
would serve as the wellspring of life
for each universe the mine stone would
allow all forms of life to achieve
higher states of consciousness the time
stone would provide the passage of time
for all moments between the universes
formation and his destruction and the
power stone for serve as a foundation by
which all the other stones could operate
at their peak capacities
and so with the formation of our
universe some 13.8 billion years ago
this space would give birth to varying
cosmic entities representing an aspect
of the universe itself to this end the
cosmic entities of eternity infinity
death and entropy came to represent life
death existence and destruction watching
on as the newly formed multiverse began
to take form the remaining Celestials
took to this new multiverse creating
duplicates of themselves and copying
their power to each universe all the
while seeding life-sustaining worlds
with their offspring as a means to
increase their number
however believing their role as the sole
creators and shapers of life was being
usurped the Celestials seized the
Infinity stones and destroyed the cosmic
entities fancying themselves divine with
no equal in the cosmos returning to what
they viewed as their natural role in
their hubris the Celestials failed to
recognize the balance that they had
created with the destruction of the
cosmic entities and were thus met with
the arrival of the Living Tribunal
judging against the cosmic tyrants the
tribunal restored the cosmic entities
and decreed that the hierarchy of the
one above all was beyond reproach
warning the Celestials but should they
attempt to move beyond their station
again their entire race would be met
with complete and total destruction and
so recognizing the tribunals authority
the Celestials grudgingly accepted their
new role within the universe as creators
and shepherds to the evolutionary
process of all sentient beings
following this and remaining within our
universe the Celestials began traveling
the space waves with each new
life-sustaining world they discovered
the Celestials would use their vast
power to plant the building blocks of
life on each world like a grand cosmic
experiment after a period of 19 cosmic
cycles the Celestials led by Arish and
the judge would return to each planet
for a 50-day period of examination in
what became known as a host the first
host would analyze the planetary life
select its dominant race and alter its
genetic structure one third of that race
would have their genes accelerated to
the peak of their races evolutionary
state granting them vast cosmic energies
and we go forward as eternals another
third would have their genes
destabilized creating unchecked physical
mutations and would go forward as
deviance finally the last third would
have their genes modified to provide the
potential for future mutation after a
predetermined period of time and while
this time period varied from one world
to the next the result was that once
this final third reached an evolutionary
threshold the genes would begin to
activate granting powers ranging from
simple telekinesis and shape-shifting to
total control of the fabric of reality
itself the arrival of the second host
would provide a period of observation by
the Celestials unlike the first host
which served as a prime mover the second
and third hosts would simply monitor
their experiments ensuring that the
roles established for the Eternals and
the deviance across the universe remain
unchanged and that should either group
abandon their role the consequences
would be swift and harsh finally the
fourth celestial host wouldn't Herman if
their experiments were worth saving or :
and what has become known as the day of
judgment Aaron would judge the
worthiness of their planetary
experiments by analyzing their desires
their actions both past and present as
well as the overall progression of the
planets race
if the Celestials were satisfied they
would leave their experiments to
continue on their path without
interference however if the Celestials
were displeased err Ashim would judge
against their experiments using the
power stone Isan the searcher would then
be tasked to completely cleanse the
world in question eradicating all forms
of sentient and organic life in turn the
celestial gardener would plant life
seeds which would begin the life growing
process once again as a result this role
undertaken by the Celestials became
their standard course throughout the
entirety of the universe traveling from
world to world
the celestial would conduct vast cosmic
experiments all the while having no idea
that on a small blue world in the Sol
system the totality of their experiments
would come to fruition in the form of a
young woman
it was the first film we had done is her
own studio I had been involved in Marvel
had been involved in certain at certain
levels on other films before Iron Man 1
but always as a partner never as the
lead decision-maker and I learned a lot
working on other films and other Studios
other Marvel films at other Studios up
to that point and when we got the chance
to do it ourselves it was it was there
was a lot of pressure involved but I was
very comfortable with that because if we
were to fail at least we would have
failed with the best intentions